je remercie monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la défense monsieur le
ministre
à peine élu françois hollande a pu
compter sur nos armées pour maintenez à
bien l'opération serval au mali grâce à
la loi de programmation militaire votée
en 2009 en 2013 vous avez pourtant
décidé de revoir à la baisse le format
de notre défense avec votre loi de
programmation militaire voté par votre
majorité vous avez ainsi pris le risque
d'affaiblir nos forces armées
malgré un contexte international
excessivement dangereux en 2015 faut
d'avoir écouté nos propositions la
situation s'est tellement détériorée que
vous avez décidé dans l'urgence absolue
de faire adopter par le parlement une
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
dit actualisées pour autant cette
nouvelle loi qui n'est pas à la hauteur
des enjeux n'a pas apporté de réponse
satisfaisante à cette dégradation de
notre outil militaire la déclaration
récente d'un général lors d'une
conférence publique le confirme je le
cite ouvrez les guillemets nous
consommons le matériel une année d'opex
équivaut à 2 5 années en métropole dans
cinq ans notre capital sera entièrement
consommée fermez les guillemets
quand un autre armée de l'air elle ne
peut pas aligner aujourd'hui plus de 20
appareils en opex faute de moyens
suffisants
depuis 2012 malgré les dangers qui
menacent la france françois hollande à
privilégier le recrutement de 60 mille
fonctionnaires supplémentaires pour le
compte du ministère de l'éducation
nationale au détriment de ces corps et
entendu est une priorité
le budget de la défense monsieur le
ministre même si vous pouvez encore
compter sur l'engagement admirable de
nos soldats
compte tenu de l'importance de l'effort
que vous exigez de quotidiennement
allez vous enfin obtenir contraitement
du président de la république
l'engagement de faire du budget de la
défense une priorité absolue
merci la parole et à monsieur jean yves
le drian mini la défense monsieur le
député philippe meunier je voudrais vous
remercier de me donner l'occasion de
rappeler ici que pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la république
une loi de programmation en cours
d'exécution a été révisée à la hausse
merci de me donner cette opportunité de
le dire
merci aussi monsieur meunier de me
donner l'opportunité de rappeler que le
président de la république a décidé de
renforcer les crédits affectés à nos
armées de 3,8 milliards d'euros d'ici
merci de me donner l'occasion aussi de
redire que à la demande du président de
la république il a été décidé pour la
première fois depuis très longtemps de
réviser à la hausse les effectifs
militaires qui vont monter de plus de
22000 personnel d'ici la fin de 2019
merci monsieur meunier de me donnez
l'occasion de dire ici devant
l'assemblée de le rappeler à l'assemblée
nationale que pour la première fois
depuis très longtemps il a été mis fin
aux ressources exceptionnelles ce que de
nombreux parlementaires demandait s'est
enfin réalisé et le financement des
dépenses de défense est assurée par des
crédits budgétaires réel contrairement
auparavant merci enfin monsieur le
député de me permettre de rappeler que
les opex sont financées à l'euro l'euro
à chaque année en fin d'exercice
merci de cette contribution personnelle
de vous allez fort national de notre
défense merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur alain fauré